not so it's lovely to see you here
collect ammonia today good to see you
and it's good to be here now of course
I'm sure lots of people have been asking
you about Game of Thrones we all loved
seeing you in that show last time we saw
you you were locked in a vault so the
question has to be how good's do you
think your character is at holding his
breath sure the vault was airtight
I'm not actually sure about that but I
think he's pretty good at holding his
breath but only for maybe a minute or so
happened to him I mean did you know when
you took on the role like what the
character was in the book yes I did I
did although you know when we create the
characters are for the TV show it was
slightly different from the book
character in the sense that he's a
little bit more masculine and he doesn't
cry all the time you know and he's he's
someone who knows exactly what once and
exactly out how he's gonna get it he's
actually very ruthless you know and he
shows that as their as the series goes
on I think it's in the books though you
didn't actually get locked in a vault
did so he was not that kind of oh is he
still alive or is he not still alive
no there isn't there isn't and if you've
read the books you know that he appears
again later at the series so what you
know the series is departs at some
points during the book but during the
series from the book so you know you
never know
Zara may be back again we'll see how
much would you like to kind of break
open of all and come storming out
I'd love to come back together friends I
mean it's it's definitely in my top two
TV shows of all time I would say the
wire and Game of Thrones are my favorite
TV shows so to be involved in it again
to be involved in it at all was an honor
so to come back and do it again will be
a dream
it's funny you should say that because
if you've seen it I'm sorting Twitter
the other day someone's done a kind of
meme of Omar from the wire instead of
saying winter is coming it says Omar's
coming he's kind of dressed or like if
he was he would know I know I was
shooting when I was showing in this game
in New Orleans I met Michael Kay
Williams who plays Omar and I'm as bad
as because wire is like one of my
options right before I could say he was
like Game of Thrones ro and it was like
it showed me just exactly how much it
transcends different ages you know
genres because this is remember this is
a fantasy TV show and before Game of
Thrones you wouldn't get this many
different types of people watching this
show so it spread to so many different
people cultures and press the worlds as
it's touched everybody says if you could
have sorrow bursting back once the scene
what would you like to see him do on the
show well I'd like to see him make peace
with Khaleesi and somehow join forces of
her and rule the world but I don't know
if he came back if she would be so
merciful I don't know he'd have to be
bearing gifts and we've seen so many
great deaths on the show over the four
seasons but who fee U stands out in
season four as having a particularly
memorable death the most relevant is
Joffrey and everybody must have been
just laughing with glee
you know when they saw his eyes bulging
at his eyes turned red and the froth
coming out of his mouth I thought that
was that was great I mean you've been
waiting for that sour I've been waiting
for that to happen since I knew that it
was coming but I did it the whole web so
when it happened the way happened it was
just like amazing I was I wasn't like
when the red wedding I was silence
and you know the credits rolled and I
could hardly speak and they didn't play
any music it was really a motive was
really kind of but when Joffrey died I
was happy he loved it I called people up
yes kids decked you know it was it was
great fun that is that's what makes it
great TV he's such a great character as
well Geoffrey wasn't he has so many
fantastic moments I mean for you if you
watch the four season so far in what
moment stood out for you of Joffrey on
screen I think when you really see his
real the level of evil that will go to
like when he shows Sansa his father's
head her father's head on a spike him
and when the two prostitutes are in the
room with him and he gets that that
ornament I don't know whether he beats
her with it will sticks it somewhere
either way it's cruel it's really cool I
know you know I think you know stand out
as the moments that you see the level
that his character will go to you know
and we had some amazing moments as well
so many of the cast but just thinking of
that the Lannister family I mean yours
dances Tywin as well it's had some
pretty standout moments hasn't he
watered them in the moments viewed as
stood out for Charles dance I you know
what from the moment he was introduced
in season 1 when I still think for me as
an actor it's the most impressive thing
to see him skinning a deer and doing the
scene at the same time for an actor that
is really I mean obviously there's gonna
have ways of doing it but the way it was
done you he looked as though he's done
it before that was something he does
every week you know and as a character
study to watch that as an actor so it's
a masterclass a lesson and he really is
somebody who's been doing it for years
and you can learn those from George RR
Martin's mentioned the possibility for
Game of Thrones film and what do you
think about that and what would you like
to see happen I would love to see a game
of Thrones film I just I think it would
have to be almost like the end of the
series would be like you would
encapsulate in one film rather than
trying to do trying to do the whole
series as a film because I don't that
you couldn't come I mean it's taken us
four episodes just to get through three
books for series seasons to get through
three you know
we go through three books so for me it
would probably be if you're gonna do the
whole thing in the film it'll it would
be key points or just doing the last
book as a film but I'd love to see a
movie of Game of Thrones the thing is if
you're gonna do a film of gaming threads
would have to be of such quality that
because the TV show is like a film
anyway to me it's so great they can work
it on Game of Thrones compared to
working on film so for me it if they
were gonna find the value of making a
film and making it that much higher
quality than TV sure I would love to see
her I mean characters in Game of Thrones
do have a very tough time don't they
Anna when did what you thought quality
wise you need to survive and go with
rose what kind of skills what kind of
qualities you need to thrive in that
world oh well you need to be devious you
need to be cunning you need to be able
to you know smile at somebody and stab
them in the back at the same time I
think those are qualities that you need
kindness and and mercy do not get you
very far in this world I think you're
only showing mercy to people in order to
help for them to help you get where you
want to go so you can stab them in the
back so you can rule I think everybody's
got their eyes on the Iron Throne and no
one is out to help anybody unless they
can get something for it
I'm speaking the Iron Throne who would
you like to see on the Iron Throne at
the end of the day well I don't want to
say I want to be biased because I've
worked with her I think Khaleesi I would
really like she's gone under for me the
biggest journey of all the characters
and I think that I'm for her to return
victorious and beyond the throne would
be you know that'd be ideal for me was
it like working with the media Clarke
she's brilliant she's a great actress
and you know she's really dedicated to
the role and puts in so much work and
effort with the character that she plays
and with her fitness training
you know she I've seen the work that she
puts in it's not easy and you know she
does a great job and she's amazing to
work with
you